are their rugs and these is it are they
pasteurize the American eggnog is
horrible I hate eggnog so much and I
hate head not equally if not more than
her I'm gonna taste bad and that's just
a fact it's like milk or something ready
to get kind of curdles like the idea of
egg in a drink just sounds like very
unappetizing to me are they alcoholic
maybe I'd nod from like anywhere else is
better
[Music]
sounds like Bailey's Cheers
[Music]
it tastes kind of like Mexican ice cream
I kind of taste like pina colada
I got creamy pina colada it tastes to me
like if they have tunker tastes like
Christmas I liked it the amount of
alcohol is nice because I don't taste it
and if I taste it I wouldn't want to
drink it I'm thinking Puerto Rico does
it right damn this one's good you're
like coming up
[Music]
it doesn't look too bad it looks kind of
like a like a coffee type dream oh it
smells like a pumpkin pie
well I don't like this one so much
holy [ __ ] that is amazing the cinnamon
just Oh totally see myself getting
wasted to these at my Christmas Eve
party I'm still getting used to how
thick like the consistency but it tastes
really good it doesn't taste like eggnog
I do think like you're like this is very
alcoholic and I would not have known
that until after I drank it and then I
would feel it melted off a milkshake I
like it
drank almonds I did what is wrong with
me I love all the different textures and
flavors um I like that there's more than
just like blandness I think I like the
cinnamon and I like the idea of having
like a chilled eggnog I didn't realize
that there were so many different kinds
I ignore I thought they all tastes of
like [ __ ] but I was wrong like I just
picture eggnog like globbing out of them
like oh these are good I go to a party
where someone brought homemade eggnog I
think I will try it whereas previously I
definitely wouldn't have because I would
have just assumed it tastes like shitty
grocery store eggnog I'm converted I
would drink these I didn't choose the
eggnog life I would Sivan chose me
[Music]